[Music]
it's a warm summer evening and
you're enjoying a barbecue with your
family and friends
the sunny skies suddenly turn dark as a
storm blows in
you hear thunder and know that lightning
is on its way
this is how to survive a lightning
strike
there are five different ways you can
get hit by lightning
[Music]
a direct strike is what people usually
think of first
it's definitely the most dramatic and
deadliest of strikes since
it can travel through your nervous and
cardiovascular systems
but it's far from the most common
the most common strikes are ground
currents
these ripple through larger areas and
are the leading cause of
lightning-related injury
and death anything metal like
plumbing or faucets are highways for
lightning
happens when you're in contact with any
of these easy access points
which sometimes even includes doors and
windows
and then there are side flashes these
happen when
lightning bounces off something like a
tree or telephone pole
that flash of current will hit anyone
near these tall objects
the final way to get hit by lightning is
through streamers
these energy bursts happen when the
atmosphere
becomes charged with electricity
streamers
move upwards from objects and people
close to the ground
you have a 90 chance of survival if
you're hit by lightning but
you'll still face painful injuries
deafness burns brain injuries
memory loss nerve damage and seizures
are just a few of the lasting issues
that could plague you
where is the safest place to shelter
what areas should you avoid
and what is the best position to survive
step one know when lightning is coming
lightning doesn't just strike when a
thunderstorm is above your head
it may still be a clear day
lightning can happen as far as 16
kilometers away from the thunderstorm
so pay attention to signs that lightning
is in the air
if your skin starts to tingle or if the
hair on your arms
starts to rise that's a sure sign of
electricity
and if you hear thunder or a clicking
noise
that's another sign to get somewhere
safe
step two hop into a car
seeing as most people don't carry around
a suit of armor or a faraday suit
a car is your best bet
make sure the windows are closed and
don't touch anything metal
lightning will travel through the metal
of the car and into the ground
passing by you harmlessly
step 3 avoid water open areas
or caves
if you can't shelter in a car then it's
good to know what to avoid
do not shelter under anything that's not
enclosed like
a golf cart or a gazebo avoid open areas
especially hills stay away from bodies
of water
pools rivers lakes get away from them
all
if you're on a boat well i'm sorry
lightning is only dangerous if you're on
a boat
hiding under a cave entrance or other
overhang
seems smart but in reality you will be
acting as a conductor
and lightning will seek you out
step 4 make yourself small
shrink your physical footprint as small
as possible by crouching down
and placing your head between your knees
similar to a tight ball
cover your ears with your hands to
prevent any hearing loss
your head acts as the entry point for
lightning which
travels through you and out your feet
the smaller you make that distance the
better your chance at surviving with
minimal injuries if you have a backpack
or a foam mat hop on that
according to the national oceanic and
atmospheric administration
you have a 1 in 3 000 chance of being
hit by lightning in your lifetime
so remember the helpful motto when
thunder roars
go indoors that way
you can safely watch the beautiful
lightning storm
on your couch just don't touch the
windows
but you should still be prepared for any
circumstance like
if lightning struck your house and
started a fire
[Music]
it's a good thing we have more videos to
weather various hazardous conditions
check them out on how to survive
[Music]
you